shocking claims that one of the
country's largest christian
denominations suppressed allegations of
sexual abuse for years a scathing new
report commissioned by the southern
baptist convention describes decades of
cover-ups within its clergy and
membership and leadership
the sbc is a network of roughly 47 000
independently run baptist churches with
more than 14 million members nationwide
nikki bautista is following this story
for us nikki this was a
self-commissioned report good morning
indeed tony good morning the report
alleges that claims of abuse were
catalogued internally for more than a
decade with little to no follow-up or
discipline for alleged perpetrators even
as sbc leadership was made aware of
accusations facing clergy the report
says its main concern was quote avoiding
any potential liability
the independent investigation
commissioned by the southern baptist
convention concluded that members of the
group's executive committee responded
with resistance stonewalling and even
outright hostility to almost two decades
of sexual abuse allegations against
clergy according to the report they kept
a secret running list of accused baptist
ministers to avoid being sued even as
the committee publicly claimed it didn't
have the authority to create such a list
more than 400 people on it were believed
to be affiliated with the sbc at some
point but the report quotes a may 9 2019
internal email where the sbc's then
general counsel called the focus on
sexual abuse
a satanic scheme to completely distract
us from evangelism every day is a
struggle
since i've come forward publicly hannah
kate williams filed a lawsuit against
the sbc on friday alleging that she was
physically abused by her own father a
pastor for years she says it began when
she was as young as four years old and
turned into sexual abuse on her eighth
birthday but when she sought help from
the sbc leadership she says nothing ever
happened when i was kicked down i was
called a liar i was called mentally
deranged incompetent
an enemy of god the report says the sbc
used its system of granting churches
autonomy to deflect accountability for
local offenders but allegations of abuse
go up to the very top including a sexual
assault claim against former sbc
president johnny hunt which he denied in
a facebook post sunday night what as a
survivor would you like to see change i
would like to see
leaders taking the recommendations of
outside experts not as attacks on their
beliefs
but as
tools to protect those in their care
in a statement the sbc's executive
committee said it was reviewing the
report and is quote committed to doing
all we can to prevent future instances
of sexual abuse in churches we also
reached out to hannah kate williams
father for comments but have not heard
back in the past few months i've spoken
with about a dozen other women and men
who claim they were sexually abused by
southern baptist convention leaders at
the time of the alleged abuse their ages
ranged from 9 to 14. those survivors are
all past their statutes of limitations
which means they can't file a lawsuit in
their respective states each of them
told me they hope this independent
report will lead to accountability and
this really reminds me of the catholic
church abuse survivors i've spoken with
in the past and each of these survivors
have said we just want to be believed
and i think this report will finally be
a step in the right direction that's an
awful story you know it's bad when
you're suing your own father you just
don't expect to hear sexual abuse and
church in the same sentence but
unfortunately we've heard this story
before she's incredibly brave yeah i
think so too thank you nikki